tomar porque ha generado tanto revuelo
porque ha sido tan impactante este caso
de dopaje en particular fundamentalmente
por la edad de la persona involucrada es
la atleta más joven de todos los tiempos
en dar positivo en unos juegos olímpicos
con apenas 15 años el anterior había
sido reclamo en red de mont un nadador
estadounidense que dio positivo
básicamente por un error de
procedimiento en los juegos olímpicos
del 72 no se reportó una extensión de
uso terapéutico del medicamento que él
empleó en esa oportunidad el caso de que
valiera sea tan joven hace que tenga que
ser tratada como una persona protegida
según los protocolos de la agencia
mundial antidopaje y del olimpismo en
general y ahora se está lanzando una
investigación en torno alrededor de su
entorno estamos hablando hay dos
personas claves dentro de ese entorno el
médico que está asistiendo al equipo
philippe aquí en un médico que ya estuvo
involucrado en dopaje del equipo ruso
en 2007 y ahora está habilitado para
trabajar con el equipo de patinaje y el
otro personaje al que se está mirando
muy de cerca st berizzo que es la
entrenadora del equipo quien es
considerada la mejor entrenadora del
mundo en patinaje artístico pero que a
la vez
sus métodos han sido muy cuestionadas
por tratarse de métodos muy brutales que
acaban muy pronto con la carrera de las
atletas atletas de 19 años como fue el
caso de yulia livinskaya retirada con 19
años apenas ella fue la ganadora rusa
más joven de una medalla de oro en
juegos olímpicos de invierno y a los 19
años con una anorexia nerviosa se retira
o el caso de darío se lleva que formaba
parte del equipo con el que está también
camila valjevo que no pudo asistir a
estos juegos porque tiene una fractura
de cadera por estrés de entrenamiento
una niña de apenas 15 años y eso habla
de revela métodos de repetición brutales
de los ejercicios y las rutinas